for everybody who says oh Freedom caucus
members are always causing problems in
Republican leadership Squad members
cause problems in Democrat leadership
they do the same thing on the other side
but our politics are so different
that's why people think we're always at
odds with them they seem to be marching
more in lockstep with the rest of the
party these days though especially when
it comes to War I would argue that what
they've done on their side is they've
gotten their party till Marcia locks up
with them wow you know how many Democrat
members are afraid of being primaried by
Squad members or potential Squad members
a lot of them I kind of like that to be
honest but I'm just keeping it real you
know why Chuck Schumer Chuck Schumer was
acting you know was wilding out and
starting to say all these positions he
didn't want to be primaried by AOC
that's why I hope she doesn't and look
you know I love it me and Cortez I
talked to her every now and again but
Chuck Schumer I didn't want that smoke